so at 3 25 this morning we had a report
of a fire and a three-story senior
residency high-rise
it eventually went to a three-alarm
smoke was showing from a second-story
balcony of the three-story building
fire lapping up to the third floor
second and third floors were evacuated
the bus was brought in to house those
seniors
while the firefighters put it out
they were able to confine it to the two
apartments the fire started on the
second floor
on the balcony
of one apartment and lapped up to the
balcony of the apartment and extended to
that unit on the third floor
it was confined to the two units in the
hallway on the second floor 150 thousand
dollars damage
we have no injuries in connection with
this incident
and the cause of the fire appears to be
smoking related
the occupant says that
they did smoke on the balcony late last
night before going to bed
the fire investigator says that the
patterns found on the balcony are
consistent with
the fire originating around where the
smoking material she says that she was
smoking so it's accidental
nobody hurt
crews are picking up
returning to their stations
there were no injuries in connection
with the incident
until we have a lot of people who have
mobility issues on wheelchairs how lucky
are we that we have no injuries at all
when it appears that this the hallway
was completely uh smoke filled
and a lot of these people have hearing
issues the fire alarms
did go off these doors are made to
withstand fire and smoke
and
a lot of them we had to wake them up and
the firefighters had to
take them out uh by that time we were
already starting to take smoke out of
the building so actually with the doors
closed they were like sheltering in
place
and it was probably a blessing in the
skies and that
by those people staying in their units
they didn't go into the smoke field
hallway which could have caused more
injury so it worked out really well
i was talking with a with the residents
telling me that she was in her unit
crying stuck unable to get out until
just out of nowhere firefighter
firefighters russian and jay crash was
so thankful
your thoughts
well on these newer buildings it's
little boxes that are put together to
make a big box
and if every if the conditions are right
the fire should be confined to the one
box where the
fire originated
so
the best place for you to be if you
can't get out if you open the door and
you find
the hallway full of smoke is close the
door
the door is one of the best piece
equipment fire safety equipment in a
building
it keeps fire and smoke out and
especially in buildings like this
those are extra special doors they're
much thicker it can hold back so what it
did it did what it was supposed to do
kept those elements from going in there
they were sheltering in place and they
were probably in the best place
possible the fire's not going to go
through the wall
very rarely we would have hoses already
up there
and many times we do tell people to
shelter in place because
you are better in that room than you are
anyplace else so it's always important
to do what the firefighters
tell you to do they wouldn't evacuate
those residents until we feel that the
hallway is safe enough for them to
evacuate through